Selamlar güzel arkadaşım. 9. sınıf
tayfam. Geldik nihayet sonunda o çok
istediğiniz DM'leri patlattınız. Her
attığım 9. sınıf, 10. sınıf, 11, 12.
sınıf bütün videolara yazdınız. Hocam
üçgende içtik nerede? Üçgende içtik
nerede? Korkulur bu yeni tayfadan ya.
Vallahi korkulur. Canavar gibisiniz. Her
yerden saldırıyorsunuz ama siz
isterseniz ben göndermez miyim? Ama
malum dönüşümler vardı önümüzde. Onu
hallettik, bitirdik. Şimdi 3. modülde 9.
sınıf kim serimizde geldik sayfa kaçlara
biliyor musun? Şöyle bir açalım. Sayfa
kaçlardayız hocam? Üçgende eşlik. Sayfa
44, 45, 46'nın yarısına kadar beraber
yapacağız. Sonraki derste de kaldığımız
yerden yolumuza devam edeceğiz hızlı.
Ama çok güzel şeyler anlatacağım.
Eğlenceli bölüm. Ben üçgenleri, ben
geometriyi çok severim. Lezzet aldığında
şuna benziyor biliyor musun? Hani böyle
yumurta sahanda kırarsın böyle. Tam
böyle kıyısı kıvamını ben çok sevmem.
Kıyısından bir tık ilerisini düşün. Bir
tık daha pişti. Ama ekmeğe bandın mı
böyle ekmeği koydun mu şey çıkıyor yani
azıcık. Çok yoğun çıkmıyor. Birazcık
çıkıyor. En son tabanın dibini sıyırana
kadar böyle o lezzet hiç gitmez ya. Hep
böyle güzelleşir ya. Üçgenler öyle. Gel
gel gel. Bu nasıl bir tariftir? Aç
karnına da çekmiyorum ama üçgende eşlik.
İki üçgenin eşliğinden bahsedeceğim. Bir
kere Türkçe karşılık olarak eşlik
dediğimde ne anlarsın? İki üçgen eşse
eğer birbirinin tıpkısının aynısıdır.
Birbirinin tıpkısının aynısı demek bir
üçgende şunla başlanır. Kenar kenar
kenar eşitlik teoremi. Şimdi eş
olabilmesi için üçgenlerin belli
teoremler sıralıyorsun. Mesela birincisi
bu. Hocam eğer iki üçgenin karşılıklı
olarak bütün kenarları birbirine eşitse
bu üçgenler eşit üçgendir. Misal elimde
ABC üçgeni var. Elimde ne var? MK üçgeni
var. Doğru mudur? Şimdi AC arasındaki
uzunlukla km arasındaki uzunluk
birbirine eşit. Adam demiş ki dur bunu
eşitleyeyim. BC arasındaki uzunlukla KL
arasındaki uzunluk birbirine eşit. Bunu
da eşitleyeyim. AB arasındaki uzunlukla
LM arasındaki uzunluk da birbirine eşit.
Gel bunu da eşitleyeyim. Karşılıklı
olarak bütün kenarları eşitlendi mi? E
ha o zaman bunlar eş üçgendir. Bitti.
Peki bunu yazarken nasıl yazacağız
hocam? ABC üçgeni eştir. Hem eşittir
koyuyorsun hem üstüne bu dalga işaretini
yapıyorsun. eşittir anlamına geliyor.
MLK üçgeni. Ama işte bak dananın
kuyruğunun koptuğu yer. En eğlendiğimiz
yerlere geldik. Nedir biliyor musun?
Mevzu burada yazılış sırası çok önemli.
Yazılış sırasından kastım şu. Bunlar
tesadüfi olarak bu sırayla yazılmadı.
Hocam alfabenin gelişine göre yazdık
değil. Burada her bir eşitliğin bir
anlamı var. Bak 1inci sıradakileri
birbirine eşitlediğinde A açısı ki nokta
açısıysa M açısı da nedir? nokta
açısıdır. Geldim. B açısı ile L açısının
birbirine eşliğini gösterir. Eğer bu
çift çizgi açısıysa burada da L açısı ne
olmak zorundadır? Çift çizgi açısı olmak
zorundadır. Bu da C açısıyla K açısının
eşitliğini gösterir. Buna küpeli açı
dersem burada da K açısı küpeli açı
olmak zorundadır. Sadece açıları değil.
Bizim burada hem benzerlikte hem
eşitlikte de kullanıyoruz biz bunları
aslında arkadaş. Bak şu kenarların ilk
ikisini aldım. Bak burada da ilk ikisini
aldım. Hocam bu tesadüf olabilir mi? Gel
bakalım. AB arasına çift çizgi demişim.
Diğerinde de ML var. Buna da çift çizgi
demişim. Bu bir tesadüf değil. Tamam mı?
Burada da BC LK. Bak bakalım şimdi düz
dünyacılar ne diyecek? Hadi dünya yine
düzdür deyin. İspat ediyoruz abi. Yani
şunu gördün mü zaten söylemen lazım. BC
BC uzunluğu tek çizgi. Geldim. LK
uzunluğunda yine tek çizgi. Hadi
üçüncüsünü de gösterelim. Göstermede
olmasın. AC uzunluğuyla da burada neyin
uzunluğunu göstermiş olacağım? MK'nin
birbirine eşit olduğunu göstermiş
olacağım. Bu kadar bu eşitlikler. Gel
hemen geçelim. Örnek soru çözelim.
Soruda veriliyorsa ne hala? Çünkü artık
biz bunun ne anlama geldiğini, nasıl
okunduğunu öğrendik. Verilen açılar var.
Alfa istiyor. Güzel. Bir bir yoluna
sokalım işi. Hocam bak diyorsun ki K
açısı ile M açısı birbirine eşit olacak.
K açısı burada 44°ce ise M açısı pembe
üçgende de 44° olmak zorunda. Aynı
şekilde geldim. L açısıyla N açısı, M
açısıyla da P açısı. P açısı belli
olduğu için daha rahatım. Şurası da ne
olacak? 26°. L açısına nokta açısı
dersem N açısına da ne diyeceğim? Nokta
açısı diyeceğim. Yetmez. Hocam bak
bakalım. Ben direkt işime lazım olanları
alıyorum. Şuradan km uzunluğu şuradan
kime eşit olmak zorunda? MP uzunluğuna
eşit olmak zorunda mı? KM uzunluğu MP
uzunluğuna eşittir. Güzel. İkizkenar bir
üçgenim var. Şu an tam sırası. Tepe
açısını bulacağım. Olayı bitireceğiz
beraber. Hemen geldik. 44 26 cevap ne
geldi? 70. 180'den 70'i çıkardık. Tepe
açımız kaç derece geldi hocam? 110. Peki
110'un içerisinde ne var? 110'un
içerisinde şurada da bir alfa var bu
arada. 2 tane alfa 110° = 180° yapıyor.
2 tane alfa buradan ne geldi? 70° alfa
eşittir kaç derece geldi hocam? 35°.
Demek ki benim aradığım alfa açısı kaç
derece olmalı? 35°. Bitti. Kökünden
kuruttuk burayı. Gel. 2 numara. Hocam
elimizde yine iki tane üçgen var. Hatta
3 tane üçgen var ama ya ben şunu görünce
rahatlıyorum aslında. Bana çok büyük
kopyayı veriyor bu. Bu verilenlere göre
x + y + z toplamı nedir? Bakalım hemen.
Ben hemen yine açılardan gideceğim. Bak
m ile p m'ye nokta dersem pardon k'ye
nokta dersem m'ye de nokta diyeceğim.
P'ye çizik dersem, P'ye çizik dersem L,
N açısına da çizik diyeceğim. L''ye L
eşit birbirineymiş. O zaman çift çizgi,
çift çizgi de birbirine eşit olacak.
Buraya kadar tamam mıyız? Güzel. Hocam,
şimdi ne söyleyebilirim? Eşit açıların
karşısında eş üçgenlerde tabii eşit
açıların karşısındaki kenar uzunlukları
da birbirine nedir? Eşittir. Noktanın
karşısı 9, noktanın karşısı 2x + 1.
Hemen yazdım. 2x + 1 eşitse 9'a 2x 8'dir
hocam. X'in değeri 4'tür. Var mı itiraz?
Ne itiraz olacak burada? Devam. Şimdi
geldim diğerine. Hocam mesela y'yi
nereden bulabiliriz diye bakıyorum. Ha
çift çizginin karşısında y + 2 var. Çift
çizginin karşısında ne var? 7 var. O
halde y + 2 eşitse 7'ye y'nin değeri
buradan kaç gelmeli? 5 gelmeli. Güzel.
Geldim sonuncusuna. P'nin karşısı burada
da çizik tabii açısı Z + 8'e tekabül
ediyor. Z + 8 neye eşittir hocam? 15'e.
Z'nin değeri buradan ne olmalıdır hocam?
9 olmalıdır ki cevap 15. Pardon 9 olur
mu ya? 7 olmalıdır ki cevap 15 gelsin.
Değil mi? Şimdi hepsinin toplamı
isteniyor. 4 + 5 + 7 dedim. 9 7 daha
toplamımız ne yaptı? 16 yaptı. Vurdum
cevabı 16'ya. Temiz. Kolay iş. Kolay
bunlar. Şimdi buraya kadar ne yaptık
biz? İki tane eş üçgene verildi. Var mı
burada iki tane eş üçgen? Söylenmiyor.
Ne verilmiş? Şu kenar [kahkaha] şu
kenara, bu kenar bu kenara eşit. Hocam
bunlar da eşit olsaydı bu üçgenler eşit
olurdu. Yazıyor mu? Eşittir yazmıyor.
Bilgileri vermiş. KPN açısını istiyor.
Bak KPN açısı dediğim yer de burası.
Tamam mı? Hatta şuraya X açısı diyeyim.
GPN. Onu bulacağız. Şimdi ben sana şunu
söyleyeyim. Şu içerideki üçgende 30 var.
75 var değil mi? 75le 30'u topladım.
Cevap ne yaptı? 105°. 180'den 105'i
çıkartma. Ha yanlışlık mı yaptık acaba
diye yapmadık. Ne geldi? 75°. Bir dakika
ya hocam. Bu da 75°erece ise eğer bu
çizik açısıysa bu da çizik açısı. Yani
benim varmak istediğim nokta buradaki
iki üçgen aslında eş üçgenler oldular
mı? Sebebi ne? Sebebi şu yazacaksın.
Kenar kenar kenar eşlik teoremine göre
hangi üçü üçgen? Kafama göre başladım
bak. KP N'yi yazdım. Üçgeni eştir
yazdım. Karşıyı yazarken dikkat
edeceğim. Dalga işareti, çızık işareti,
çift çizgi sırasıyla gittim. Burada da
öyle. Dalga işareti, çizgi işareti, çift
çizgi. O zaman burada da yazarken ne
yazacağız? MLP üçgenine eştir. Öyle
kafaya göre yazmak gitmek yok. Tamam.
Şimdi hocam o zaman şunu söyleyelim.
Misal burada bizim elimizde E P açısını
ben biliyordum. Şuradaki üçgende
buradaki P açısı kime eşit? L''ye eşit.
Bak burası da X açısı. Kabul mü? Misal N
açısına Y dersem buradaki N açısı kime
tekabül ediyor? P'ye. Burası da Y açısı
olur mu? Olur. Misal buna Z dersem demek
ki burası da ne olacaktır? Z açısı
olacaktır. Şimdi ben hemen şuradan
geldim. Bak şurası 75 180'den çıktı.
Buraya kaç derece kaldı? 105°. Aynı 105°
burada var mı? Var. O halde x + 30 +
105° = 180 ise e buranın toplamı da 135°
yaptığına göre x'e kalan yani bizim
aradığımız açı kaç derece olacaktır? 45°
olacaktır. Sayfa 44. Adım adım adım adım
bitireceğiz bunları. Geldim hemen 4.
örneğime. Şekil 1'de KLM üçgeni
biçimindeki kağıt LH boyunca kesilerek
iki parçaya ayrılıp arada hiç boşluk
bırakılmadan şekil 2'deki gibi
yerleştiriliyor. Verilen diklik var. 25
birimlik uzunluk var. LM ve KL için
şunların birbirine eşit olduğu verilmiş.
Şunlar 25 birim. Onları yazmakta fayda
var. KM uzunluğu 30 birimdir deniyor.
Şuraya geldim. 30 birim yazdım. Buna
göre L üssü M. Bak şuradaki küçücük yeri
istiyor benden. Bir kere ben sana
söyleyeyim. Elindeki üçgen nasıl bir
üçgen? Soldaki üçgenki kele. İki skenar
üçgen. İkiar üçgende tabana indirilen
dikme tabanı iki eşit parçaya ayırır mı?
Ayırır. Yani şuraya 15 birim yazarsam
buraya da 15 yazar mıyım? Yazarım.
Ortadaki kenara 20 kalır mı? Nasıl kalır
diye böyle etrafa bakma. Bana bak. 3'ü 5
ile çarptım. 4'ü 5 ile çarptım. 5'i 5
ile çarptım. Aslında 3 4 5 üçgeninin
türetilmiş hali.
Ayrıca bu nokta açısı, bu nokta açısı,
bu cızgı açısı, bu cızgı açısı 90'ları
zaten ortak. Bütün açıları, bütün
kenarları eşit. O zaman bu iki üçgen eş
üçgen. Şimdi o iki eş üçgeni buraya
yerleştireceksin. Mesela bak burası H,
burası H açısı. Yani bunların her biri
kaçar derece? 90°. Kabul müyüz? Şimdi
şuradaki K açısı, buradaki K açısı değil
mi? Aynı açı. O zaman buraya nokta
yazmaz mısın? Buradaki M açısı, buradaki
M açısı değil mi? nokta yazmaz mısın? O
zaman buna cızık kalır. Buna da cızık
kalır. Peki bu üçgenler zaten bunların
kendileri aynıları. O zaman ben şunu
söyleyebilirim. Hocam burası hipotenüs.
Buranın tamamı 25 birim. Kabul müyüz?
Tıpkı burada olduğu gibi. Geldim.
Ardından nereye hocam? Çızık. Pardon
nokta açısının karşısında hangi kenar
var? 20 birimlik kenar var. O halde
geldim. Şuraya da 20 birim yazdım mı? Şu
arada kalan parça ben oraya x dersem
aslında 25 - 20'den x'in uzunluğu kaç
birim bulunur? 5 birim bulunur. Olay
biter. Benden de zaten orayı istiyor ya.
Bu kadar gençlik bu sorular. Peki geldim
önemli bir noktaya. Biz iki tane üçgen
gördük. Bunlar hadi bakalım. Kenar kenar
kenarı sağlamıyor. Eş olamaz
demeyeceğiz. Farklı yol nemleri de var
bu işin. Bunlardan biri de açı kenar açı
eşlik teoremi. 2 numara diyelim. Hadi
buna da. Şimdi açı kenar açı eşitlik
teoremi deyince ne anlıyorsun? Açı kenar
sonra bir tane daha açı birbirine eşit
olacak. Anlıyorsun değil mi? Öyle değil.
Bak yani öyle de öyle değil derken şöyle
şimdi bir tane mavi çubuk yaptım. Tamam.
Bir tane çoğaltalım. Bak aynısından hiç
bozmadan koyuyorum. Bir tane de kırmızı
çubuk yapacağım şimdi. Bir tane de
kırmızı çubuk yaptım. Çoğaltıyorum. Yine
aynısından koyuyorum. Şimdi tek
yapacağım şu. Bunu ikisini birleştirdim.
Tamam mı? Belli bir açıyla birleştirdim.
Şuraya da siyah çubuğu koydum. Şimdi bir
düşün bakalım. Bu siyah çubuğun uzunluğu
aynı kırmızıyı
şey yapmadan, boyutunu değiştirmeden bu
sefer daha dar açı yapacak şekilde
yerleştirdim
ve ardından yine mavi ile kırmızıyı
birleştirdim. Bak maviler eşit,
kırmızılar eşit ama bunlar birbirine
eşit olmak zorunda değil. Neden? Aradaki
açı bunu etkiledi. He ben o kırmızıyı
yerleştirirken bunu da beta açısı kadar
yapsaydım siyahların uzunluğu birbirine
eşit olurdu. Ne anlatmaya çalışıyorsun?
Karşılıklı olarak eşit olan iki kenar
arasındaki açılar da eğer birbirine eşit
olursa bu üçgenler eştir. Yani buradaki
yazım bir tesadüf değil. Ben birçok
okulda, birçok yerde görüyorum.
Şaşkınlıktan küçük dilimi yutacağım.
Açı, kenar, açı. İki tane açı arasındaki
kenar. Bu üçlü eşit olduğunda biz bu iki
üçgene eş üçgen diyeceğiz. Anladın mı
şimdi sebebini? Bu önemli bir
ayrıntıydı. Burada da zaten deminden
beri gösterdiğimiz O eşitlik şeyi var.
Gösterimi var. O eşitlik gösterimiyle
kullanacağımız örnekler çözelim. Şimdi
örnek 1. Km doğrusal noktalar falan
filan geç abi. 3 tane eşitlik var. Geç.
38 birim var. Yazmakta fayda var hocam
bunu. KP uzunluğu 38 birim. Şuraya
38'imi yapıştırdım. NP uzunluğu
neredesin? O zaten üstünde yazıyor. 15
birim. KL uzunluğu bana soruluyor. KL'ye
gitmeye çalışım. Şuraya X dedim. Şuraya
X dedim. Şuraya X dedim. Kabul müyüz? KL
kaç birimdir? Geleceğim abim. Geleceğim.
Dur bakalım. Nasıl geleceğiz oraya? KL
kaç birimdir? Ne yapılabilir? Şunu
yapalım mı? Soldaki üçgen nasıl bir
üçgen? KLM üçgeni ikizkenar üçgen.
İkizkenar üçgende tabana indirilen dikme
tabanı tam olarak ne yapar? Ortadan
ikiye böler hocam. Yani bu parça bu
parçaya eşit olacak. Hatta hatta burası
nokta açısıysa burası noktadır. Eğer bu
çızık açısıysa bu da çizıktır. Kabul mü?
Şimdi açı taşımayı çok iyi bilmen
gerekiyor. 90 nokta çızık 3ü bir araya
geldiğinde ne oluşturuyor? 180 derece
oluşturuyor.
Nokta 90 180 yapabilmen için bu ne
olmalı? Çızık. Aynı şekilde burası da
artık ne olacak? Nokta. Peki bu
üçgenlerin nokta pardon çızık nokta
arasında kenar uzunluğu ne? Dalga. Nokta
çızık kenar uzunluğu ne? X yani dalga.
Nokta çızık ikisi arasındaki kenar
uzunluğu ne? Dalga. O zaman bu 3 tane
üçgen de eş üçgendir. Misal hocam bunun
eşliğini bana bir yazabilir misin dersen
yazayım. Mesela şuraya H diyeyim ben. KL
Heni
eştir bak sıralama önemli. Nokta, dalga,
çizgi. Aynı şekilde nokta, dalga, çizgi.
M, L, Hgi. Kafaya göre yazmıyorum zaten.
Yazamam. Öyle bir dünya yok. O da
eşittir kime hocam? Yine noktadan
başladık deminden beri. Nokta, dalga,
çizgi yolumuza bakıyoruz. O zaman ne
diyorum? N, M P üçgeni bu üçü birbirine
eştir dedim. Şimdi soruyu bitirme vakti.
Niye? Bu üçgenler birbirineşse eğer
çızığın karşısında 15 birim varsa
çızığın karşısında 15 birim vardır.
Çızığın karşısında 15 birim vardır. 15
15 burası ne yapar? 30. Şuraya ne kalır?
8. Peki 8 15 ne üçgeni vardı hocam? 17.
O halde x dediğim uzunluk ne oldu? 17.
Soru benden neyi istiyordu? KL'yi
istiyordu. KL dediğim yerde X uzunluğuna
eşitti. Doğru cevap 17'dir. Zor mu ya?
Zor mu gözünü seveyim? Zor mu? Sorarım
sadece. Aşağıda 3 eş 3 eş dik üçgen. Aha
büyük kopya geldi. Bu üçgenler birbirine
eş. Açıları, kenarları, alayları
birbirine eşit. Kartondan oluşturulmuş
düzlemsel bir yapı var burada. şunların
düzlemsel olduğunu söylüyor. Bunlar
düzlemselse birbirine paraleldir. Burası
90 derecedir. Zaten şurada da galiba bir
90° oluşuyor. Yukarıdaki şekilde birim
cinsinden verilen uzunluk ölçülerine
göre X ile gösterilen uzunluk ne
kadardır? Şuradaki hipotenüsü arıyoruz.
Bunların üçü birbirine eşitse bütün
açıları da birbirine eşit. Mesela ben
buna nokta açısı diyeyim. Buna çızık
açısı diyeyim. Bak şimdi şurası 90° ya
da bunun birbirine paralel olduğunu
düşün. Hop. Buraya ne kaldı hocam? Nokta
açısı. Çızık açısı, nokta açısı, çizik
açısı. Kabul mü? Şimdi eşit açıların
karşısındaki kenar uzunlukları da eşit
olacak. Ben misal çizsna geldim. X'i
kullanmış mıydık? Y diyelim mesela o
zaman buraya. Şurası Y kenarı olsun.
Çızığın karşısı. Al sana çızığın karşısı
Y. Al sana çizin karşısı Y. Bak Y'yi
çizgi gördüğüm her yere yapıştırdım.
Tamam mı? Şimdi geldim. Eee, nereye
bakabiliriz diye. Şuraya bakabilir
miyiz? Nokta kenarın karşısı belli
burada. Y + 7. Noktanın karşısı burada
ne olmak zorunda? Y + 7 olmak zorunda.
Burası da noktanın karşısında Y + 7. Ama
benim özellikle ilgileneceğim üçgen bu.
Şimdi bak bu üçgen nasıl bir üçgen? Dik
üçgen. Kenar uzunlukları ne? Y var, y +
7 var. Bir de Y + 9 var. Normal
şartlarda bilgisiz bir öğrenci şunu
yapar. Bu der ki hipotenüs. O zaman
hocam ben burada hipotenüs kuralı
yaparım. Bilgisiz derken tamam Pisagor
teoremini biliyor ama yapılmaz. Yani bu
soruda şimdilik gerek yok. Bu işlemi
çözmeye çalışır. Abi böyle çözülmez bu
soru. Yani bu denklem çözülür mü ya? Biz
ne yapacağız orada? Özel üçgen
düşüneceğiz. 8 15 17 özel üçgenini
düşün. Bak y eğer 8 olsaydı 8 7 daha ne
yaptı? 15. Y eğer 8 olsaydı ne yaptı? 8
9 daha 17 sağlıyor. Demek ki Y değerini
aslında soruda burada keşfedebiliyorum
ben. 8'dir. Y 8. Bitmedi işim. X'i
istiyorum ya. X zaten bu üçgenin
hipotenüsü değil mi ya? 17 olan. Bitti
soru hocam. Yani sağlayan değeri bulunca
zaten soruyu bitirmiş oldum. X dediğim
değer 17 birimdir. Sayfa 45'te biter mi
hocam? Çok temiz işçilik. Çok temiz
işçilik. Son iki sorum. 9. Dersin sonunu
burada yapacağız beraber. 3üncü örnek bu
da KLMN dikdörtgen verilenlere göre LP24
KN 7 birimdir. Bu verilenlere göre X kaç
birimdir? Şimdi ben eşit iki kenarı
gördüm. Hemen onları bir test edeyim.
Nedir onlar? LM uzunluğuyla
MN MN uzunluğu. Şimdi şunları ben üst
çok kalın oluyor ya böyle. Şöyle yeşille
bir çizsem şurası bir de şurası
birbirine eşit. Doğru mu? Ha bir dakika
hocam. Şimdi bak şurada ne var? 90° var.
Başka da bir şey yok elimde yalnız ya.
Hani diklikler veriliyor falan. 3 tane
diklik veriliyor. Ben ikisini
görebiliyorum. Neden? Bir bakalım.
Bir şey eksik çünkü değil mi? KN NK ya
da KM'ye dik zaten. Burası bingo.
Bulduk. Nm
ml'ye dik. Hah. Bana bunu vermen
lazımdı. Eğer burası 90 derece ise buna
nokta bu cızık dersem noktayla 90 derece
yapar. Birbirini tamamlar. Buraya nokta
buraya da çızık kenarı kalır. Doğru
mudur mantımız? Güzel. Bak mantımız şu.
Bu ikisi 90'sa burası çizik olduğunda bu
da nokta olmalı ki 90'a tamamlayayım. 90
90 180 yapsın. Bu üçgenler nasıl?
Üçgenler eş. Noktanın karşısı 7 ise
noktanın karşısı ne olmak zorunda hocam?
7 birim olmak zorunda. Bu üçgenler eş
üçgenler. 724 çorbacı üçgeni 7 24 25
üçgeni diye bir üçgen var. 90'ın karşısı
da o. Misal bak burası 25 ama şunu
biliyorum. Çızgının karşısı burada kaç?
24. Şuranın tamamı 24'tür. Hocam soru
bitmiştir. X + 7 eş 24'e X e= ne
olacaktır? 14 olacaktır ki cevabım 20.
Hoppa. Olur mu ya hocam? Sen de ne
yapıyorsun ya? X = Aa ben niye
çıkaramadım ya? 17 olacaktır değil mi? X
cevabımız 17 birimdir dedim. Noktarı
koydum. Soru benden sadece x istiyordu.
Günün son sorusu. Buraya kadar geldik.
Canavar gibi 20şer dakikada ortalama.
Sen videoyu beğenirsen, yorum atarsan
gelirsen. Bir de nereye gelmeni
bekliyorum ben senin? Bir saniye bekle.
Nereye gelmeni bekliyorum?
Rehbermatematik.com'a. Bütün ücretsiz
PDF'lerimiz, her şeyimiz burada gençlik.
Burada sadece aynı zamanda PDF'lerin
olduğu yer değil. Deneme sınavlarına
girebildiğiniz bizim sizler için
hazırladığımız denemelerimiz burada.
Blog yazılarımız burada. RMüst benim şu
an en beğendiğim yerlerden biri oldu.
İnşallah siz de verirsiniz. Maarif
modele özel burada bilgi yarışmaları
yapıyoruz. Bak ben bugün daha çözmemişim
ama haftalıkta var mıyım? Bu gerçi
pazartesiden başlıyor. Şubat'a bakalım.
4. sıradayım. Bak bu arkadaşlar beni
geçmiş. Vay vay vay vay vay. Yine
kampüste RM kütüphane bölümü var. Canlı
olarak ders çalıştığımız bölüm özellikle
öğleden sonra akşamüstleri buralara
gelen arkadaşlar oluyor. Beraber
buralara girip birlikte sınıf ortamında
canlı ders çalışıp hatta buradan
chat'ten de arada ben de oluyorum.
Sohbet edebiliyoruz. Hepinizi beklerim.
Tamam. Sizler için faydalı gerçekten
güzel bir site yapmaya çalıştım elimden
geldiğince kod kod satır satır. KL MN
kare KPN dik üçgen. KP diktir. PN'ye
15'e 5 verildi. PL kaç? Şimdi bunu
söyleyeyim. Bunu ben daha anlatmadan
görebiliyorsan sen olmuşsun arkadaş.
Çözemezsen de olmamışsın değil. Yalnız
görmesi biraz zor. Şimdi ek bir şey var
çünkü burada. Şimdi bak bakalım. Burada
bir üçgeni gördün. Güzel. Böyle bir
doğru çekmişler. Bunun uzunluğu
isteniyor arkadaş. Bunu daha önceden
çözmeyen adamın çözmesi biraz zor. Bunu
doğrusal uzattım gitti. Kabul müyüz?
Güzel. L''den de buraya dik olacak
şekilde uzattım ama dik. Neden böyle bir
şey yapıyorsun hocam? Aklına nereden
gelir bir insanın? Sebebi şu. Buraya
nokta açısı. Buraya 90 dersem burası
çızık olabilir mi? Olur. Orası noktaysa
burası çızık olur mu? Burası 90. Burası
çızıksa burasına ne kalır? Nokta kalır.
Şimdi düşünüyorum. Bu üçgenin baktığı
hipotenüs uzunluğu KL karesinin bir
kenarı. Bu üçgenin baktığı hipotenüs
uzunluğu yine bu karenin kn kenar
uzunluğu. Doğru mudur? Bu niye tam
oturmadı buraya? Şöyle. Evet doğrudur. O
zaman bu üçgenler nokta kenar
pardon açı kenar açıya göre açı kenar
açıya göre. Nasıl üçgenler? Eş üçgenler.
Yazalım mı? Bak nasıl olduğunu? Şuraya
mesela ne diyelim? Mehmet'in M'si var
mı? Varmış. T kenarı diyelim. T L K
üçgeni eştir nereden başlıyor? 90 nokta
çizık. 90 nokta çizık. O zaman Pk
N üçgeni. PK N üçgenine. Bu üçgenler
nedir? Eştir. Eşit açıların karşısında
eşit uzunlukta kenarlar vardır. Burası
15 ise çızığın karşısı ne olacaktır? 15.
Noktanın karşısı ne olacaktır? 5.
Noktanın karşısı ne olacaktır? 5. Şimdi
sorunun benden istediği yere
odaklanıyorum. Soru diyor ki, "Kardeş"
diyor bak diyor şurada sana dik üçgen
oluşturdum diyor. Böyle düşününce soru
kolaylaştı. Burası bir dik üçgen benim
için. İşte bu dik üçgenin senden
hipotenüsünü istemem demekle aslında bu
soru az öncekiyle aynı değil mi? Peki o
üçgeni dik üçgeni şuraya biraz
küçülterek çizsem mevzuyu görelim.
Şurası 15. 5 daha ne yaptı? 20. Şurası
20 şurası 15. Özel üçgen bu. 3 4 5'in
katlarından oluşuyor. 3'ün 3 katı 15 4
pardon 3'ün 5 katı 4'ün 5 katı 5'in 5
katı ne yapar? 25 O zaman PL uzunluğumuz
kaç birimdir hocam? 25 birimdir. Belki
de bugünün en güzel sorularından
biriydi. Hani bu derece adayı. Derece
adayı direkt derece sorusu diyemem
açıkçası ama güzel bir soruydu. Bizi
geliştiren sorulardan biriydi. 9. dersin
sonu gençlik. 10. dersimizde buradan
devam edeceğiz. Eeeceğiz, edeceğiz,
edeceğiz, edeceğiz, edeceğiz. Sonrasını
üçgende eşlikte sona getireceğim. Sonra
üçgende benzerlik teoremlerine
geçeceğiz. Seri halde bugünden itibaren
videolarımız gelmeye devam edecek. O
yüzden yola birlikte bomba gibi devam.
Hadi bakalım. Gerçekten seviliyorsunuz.
Hoş kal. Hoşça kal.
[müzik]
He. [müzik]
Yeah.